it's good yeah know so the cont
mentioned we looked at them uh and I I
think I don't know I certainly said you
look at the context of them valant man
and one experience man are different uh
we look to um have God up in will and
then the famine they both 300 years of
famine three three
years how good has a good does a good
have God no does so God has no good no
God so so if Jesus Is God should have no
good right so let me explain what the
the idea what the doctrine what the
teacher of the Trinity is you have the
the one being the one being of God with
the three persons so our beings are
human beings they're not limited or
controlled by what we are they're very
separ for our persons and our beings so
we exact same but my person is very
different to you I believe that Jesus is
God and I worship Jesus you believe that
all is God and you you bow down fast
does a good have a good so you got the
one God the Father the Son and the Holy
Spirit the god this is my friend James
here James how are you all right thank
you so the question does God have a God
no God does have a God so if Jes so J
just said no so therefore if Allah is
God and he has another God he cannot be
God anymore because all of us we do
agree God has no God but we in the Bible
when Jesus said I'm going to my God and
your God so Jesus has a God if Jesus Is
God how does he have a God doesn't make
any
sense he just told me God has no God so
either you have to be consistent by
saying okay it's true God has no God so
therefore Jesus has God therefore he
cannot be God anymore or you have to do
what start fighting with your own sound
reasoning sound intellect and your own
natural creation you going to start
wrestling with scripture because
scripture of the churches tells you
Jesus Is God therefore you going to
start thinking no even though clearly
Jesus cannot be God because he has a god
okay so are
you yeah no so we've got to go now but
it sounds like you're talking about
Roman and I'll take Romans John I'll
take that read only two verses later it
like God the father is going to glorify
Jesus but we've got to head off now GL
doesn't make any
sense anyway
take have a day
take you might want to
do just to conclude subh Allah so what
he what just happened to him now he go
surprise and he's what you call it shock
of information so he's been learning
many things in his during his lifetime
now something literally clicked in with
his sound intellect his natural
inclination so either he's going to be
honest and step back and think you know
what I need to accept Islam and
Christianity or he's going to start
struggling with his own uh uh uh
scripture either he's going to allow his
own scripture even corrupted to
overpower his sound intellect and sound
ation which Allah create us with he just
said God has no God so therefore be
consistent but Jesus had a God so
therefore logically speaking go Jesus
cannot be God